have a look at this diagram okay now
this is what we were doing before with
just establishing first principles doing
the whole rise over run thing and what I
said was you picked some x value call an
X and you say let's just go forward a
bit let's call that bit H and your X Y
or an X plus h right and that's where we
our definition of first principles came
from right now it's one definition it's
not the only one I'm going to show you
another one which is not quite as
popular but it is extremely extremely
useful in this case I'm about to show
you okay so instead of saying X and some
other play place X plus h I'm just gonna
call this other coordinates EC for some
constant okay and that makes this
distance here this distance X minus C do
you agree with that like it's just that
one - that one that's the difference now
this is X f of X if this is C then F F C
very good so just like I have run down
here I have rise here which of course is
exactly the same thing just with F right
the function evaluated at this point
okay now because we have phrased things
differently I now have a different an
alternative way to write first
principles I no longer have the limit as
H approaches 0 for starters because I
don't have an H right what I really want
is for C this number I wanted to get
closer to X so they sit on top of one
another so I have the tension on the
secant right so said of saying H
approaches zero I want C now you in some
ways you can write them either way
around but hopefully as I finish this
you'll see why I want it this way I want
C to approach X I mean in some ways see
printing X approaches C there I'm gonna
end up in the same spot now what's
happening here is rise over 1
okay he is rise and he is run so I have
this there's my dy and there's my DX ok
now you're thinking well so what like is
is it any better than the other it's not
at all obvious that this is actually
very useful to us rather than the other
form here's why I'm gonna pull it up
you've been looking and you already
noticed that oh this is our derivative
of Y right where Y is like x squared or
X cube some like that right can you see
here that this is just changing Y
changing names right but I can write
this a slightly different way like so
yeah I'm doing something too why whether
it's x squared or executed whether you
like okay what I'm doing is finding the
derivative that's what this really means
right we call this the this process of
find the derivative is differentiating I
find the derivative of differentiate
it's not called deriving please they
call that a Fibonacci
it's called differentiating so this is
called the differential operator when
you put it on the front of something it
means what it was there we differentiate
that okay there might be x squared or an
x squared minus 1 or anything there but
that just means different kids wind
effects now you have noticed that if you
differentiate x squared okay
I'll pop some to X if you differentiate
X you get 3x squared if you really want
to kill my family my account remember
one of the questions does is if you
differentiate X to the power of 4 you
get 4x cubed now tell me there's a
pattern here
I think clearly there must be a pattern
I can take advantage on now now the
patent I see is that you have something
raised to a power right that power seems
to drop out the front and become the
coefficient and the power itself reduces
by 1 that's really a 2 X to the 1 you
see that so I noticed a pattern that's
good but but why should this be the case
well watch as we use this guy okay what
I want a differentiate
is let f of X be X raised to some power
whatever power you like okay I'm going
to use first principles to show that
this is the case
okay so just according to this
definition of what somebody's on this
definition of first principles it's
going to be this is gonna be f dash the
limit as C approaches X because I want
the taejun not the secret of what's on
the new right now there is f of X and
there is f of C degree with that just
put X and C into the appropriate spot
and I am X minus C on the new on the
denominator now because I don't know
what the power of n is in its current
state I can't do anything okay but if I
did know what the power of n was it
would be okay for instance if n were to
it'll be this case right
maybe x squared minus C squared so
you'll have difference of squares right
then what would happen is in this case
here in a baby what am I gonna get I've
got X is a seeds instead of A's and B's
okay so I'm gonna get X minus C X plus C
right all over X minus C you see my
denominator that's gonna happen cancel
cancel C is gonna approach X right so
that guy is going to become X right X
plus X we as we've already notice to X
right what about this guy I'm gonna get
X minus C X squared C X C square you've
done this question in the quiz this
morning did you notice I snuck it in on
X minus C right cancel cancel all of the
C's are going to become X's so you get x
squared x squared x squared you get 3x
squared just like you're expecting okay
now you can satisfy yourself and expand
out to the power of four but do you not
see a pattern here do not see a pan
you're gonna get an A - B out the front
what will ensue all of these things this
is kind of like a binomial
nation with none of those coefficients
in there right there's no one three
three one there's no one four six four
one it's just once all right that make
sense so you can see it's gonna be what
will the first term big when I had to
this is a one yeah when this is a three
this or two and this is a for this or
three so here instead of and I'm gonna
have and minus one yep okay then I'm
gonna have a to the N minus the next one
is one down and minus two and then a B
and then n minus 3 and then B squared
all the way until what will the very
last term n minus one see the symmetry
there there in there you got it
okay now watch watch watch watch watch
look at this okay I have X's and seeds
so the limit as C approaches X or X
minus C this guy right X n minus 1 xn
minus 2 xn minus 3 all the way onto
watch my last time okay all divided by
the run X minus C there it is okay
cancel cancel okay now hold on a second
all of these seeds are gonna become X's
right every single one just like this
one and these ones okay so the first
term you're gonna have these X minus 1
doesn't every season it when this C
becomes an X what will the whole thing
baby X to the n minus 1 right and then
when these C's turn into X's it'll be X
to the N minus 1 and then all the way
because that one obviously the C will
turn to me now now I have a whole bunch
of these things how many of them do I
have I have n terms
just watch when it's a - I have two of
them when it's a three I have three of
them when it's a four I have four of
them when it's an N I have n of them and
s